hundred and twenty thousand people
evacuated to safety
that number is more than double
what most experts thought were possible
no nation
no nation has ever done anything like it
in all of history
the only the united states had the
capacity and the will and ability to do
it and we did it today
the extraordinary success of this
mission
was due to the incredible skill
bravely
and selfless courage of the united
states military and our diplomats and
intelligence professionals
for weeks
they risked their lives to get american
citizens
afghans who helped us
citizens of our allies and partners and
others on board planes and out of the
country
and they did it facing a crush of
enormous crowds seeking to leave the
country
and they did it knowing isis-k
terrorists sworn enemies of the taliban
were lurking in the midst of those
crowds
and still
the women and men of the united states
military our diplomatic corps and
intelligence professionals did their job
and did it well
risking their lives not for professional
gains
but to serve others
not in a mission of war
but an admission of mercy
20 service members were wounded in the
service of this mission
13 heroes gave their lives
i was just at dover air force base
for the dignified transfer
we owe them and their families a debt of
gratitude we can never repay but we
should never ever ever forget
in april
i made a decision to end this war
as part of that decision
we set the date of august 31st for
american troops to
withdraw the assumption was that more
than 300 000 afghan national security
forces that we had trained over the past
two decades and equipped
would be a strong adversary
in their civil wars with the taliban
that assumption
that the afghan government would be able
to hold on
for a period of time beyond military
drawdown
turned out not to be accurate
but
i still instructed our national security
team to prepare for every eventuality
even that one
and that's what we did
so we were ready
when the afghan security forces after
two decades of fighting for their
country
and losing thousands of their own
did not hold on as long as anyone
expected
we were ready when they
and the people of afghanistan watched
their own government collapse
and the president flee
amid the corruption of malfeasance
handing over the country to their enemy
the taliban
and significantly increasing the risk to
u.s personnel
and our allies
as a result
to safely extract american citizens
before august 31st
as well as embassy personnel
allies and partners
and those afghans who had worked with us
and fought alongside of us for 20 years
i had authorized 6 000
troops american troops to kabul
to help secure the airport
as general mckenzie said
this is the way the mission was designed
it was designed to operate under severe
stress and attack
and that's what it did
since march
we reached out 19 times to americans in
afghanistan
with multiple warnings
and offers to help them leave
afghanistan all the way back as far as
march
after we started the evacuation 17 days
ago
we did initial outreach and analysis
and identified around 5 000 americans
who had decided earlier to stay in
afghanistan
but now
wanted to leave
our operation allied rescue
ended up getting more than five thousand
five hundred americans out
we got out thousands of citizens and
diplomats
from those countries that went to
afghanistan with us to get bin laden
we got out locally employed staff from
the united states embassy and their
families totaling roughly 2
500 people
we got thousands of afghan translators
and interpreters
and others who supported the united
states out as well
now we believe that about 100 to 200
americans remain in afghanistan
with some intention
to leave
most of those who remain
are dual citizens
long time residents
who had earlier decided to stay
because of their family roots in
afghanistan
the bottom line 90
of americans in afghanistan who wanted
to leave were able to leave
and for those remaining americans
there is no deadline
we remain committed to get them out if
they want to come out
secretary state blinken
is leading the continued diplomatic
efforts to ensure safe passage for any
american
afghan partner or foreign national who
wants to leave afghanistan
in fact just yesterday
the united nations security council
passed a resolution
that sent a clear message about the
international community expects the
taliban to deliver on moving forward
notably
freedom of travel freedom to leave
and together
we are joined by over 100 countries
that are determined to make sure that
taliban upholds those commitments
it will include ongoing efforts in
afghanistan to reopen the airport
as well as overland routes
allowing for continued departure
to those who want to leave and deliver
humanitarian assistance to the people of
afghanistan
the taliban has made public commitments
broadcast on television
and radio across afghanistan
on safe passage for anyone wanting to
leave including those who worked
alongside americans
we don't take them by their word alone
but by their actions
and we have leverage to make sure those
commitments are met
let me be clear
leaving august the 31st
is not due to an arbitrary deadline
it was designed to save american lives
my predecessor the former president
signed an agreement with the taliban
to remove u.s troops by may the first
just months after i was inaugurated
it included no requirement that taliban
work out a cooperative governing
arrangement
with the afghan government
but it did authorize the release
of 5 000 prisoners last year
including some of the taliban's top war
commanders
among those
who just took control of afghanistan
and by the time i came to office
the taliban was in his strongest
military position
since
controlling or contesting nearly half of
the country
the previous administration's agreement
said
that if we stuck to the may first
deadline that they had signed on to
leave by
the taliban wouldn't attack any american
forces
but if we stayed
all bets were off
so we're left with a simple decision
either follow through on the commit made
by the last administration and leave
afghanistan
or say we weren't leaving and commit
another tens of thousands more troops
going back to war
that was the choice the real choice
between leaving
or escalating
i was not going to extend this forever
war
and i was not extending a forever exit
the decision to end the military lift
operations at kabul airport was based on
the unanimous recommendation
of my civilian and military advisers
the secretary of state
the secretary of defense
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff and all the service chiefs
and the commanders in the field
their recommendation
was that the safest way to secure the
passage of the remaining americans and
others
out of the country
was not to continue with 6 000 troops on
the ground in harm's way in kabul
but rather to get them out through
non-military means
in the 17 days
that we operated in kabul
after the taliban seized power
we engaged in an around-the-clock effort
to provide every american
the opportunity to leave
our state department was working 24 7
contacting and talking
and in some cases walking
americans into the airport
again
more than 5
500 americans were airlifted out
and for those who remain
we will make arrangements to get them
out if they so choose
as for the afghans
we and our partners have airlifted 100
000 of them
no country in history has done more to
airlift out the residents of another
country than we have done
it will continue
to work to help more people leave the
country who are at risk
and we're far from done
for now
i urge all americans
to join me in grateful prayer
for our troops and diplomats and
intelligence officers
who carried out this mission of mercy
in kabul
and a tremendous risk with such
unparalleled results an airmen an
airlift
that evacuated tens of thousands
to a network of volunteers and veterans
who helped identify those needing
evacuation
guide them to the airport
and provided them for their support
along the way
we're going to continue to need their
help
we need your help and i'm looking
forward to meeting with you
and to everyone
who is now offering or who will offer to
welcome afghan allies to their homes
around the world including in america
we thank you
i take responsibility for the decision
now some say
we should have started mass evacuation
sooner
and couldn't this have been done have
been done in a more orderly manner
i respectfully disagree
imagine
if we'd begun evacuations in june or
july
bringing in thousands of american troops
and evacuating more than 120 000 people
in the middle of a civil war
there still would have been a rush to
the airport
a breakdown of confidence and control of
the government
and it still would have been very
difficult and dangerous mission
the bottom line is
there is no evacuation evacuation
from the end of a war
that you can run without the kinds of
complexities
challenges threats we faced none
there are those who would say we should
have stayed indefinitely
for years on end
they asked why don't we just keep doing
what we were doing
why do we have to change anything
the fact is
everything had changed
my predecessor had made a deal with the
taliban
when i came into office we faced a
deadline may 1.
the taliban onslaught was coming we
faced one of two choices
follow the agreement of the previous
administration
and extend it to have or extend
to have more time for people to get out
or send in thousands of more troops
and escalate the war
to those
asking for a third decade of war in
afghanistan i ask
what is the vital national interest
in my view we only have one
to make sure afghanistan can never be
used again to launch an attack on our
homeland
remember while we went to afghanistan in
the first place
because we were attacked by osama bin
laden and al qaeda
on september 11
and they were based in afghanistan
we delivered justice to bin laden on may
2 2011
over a decade ago
al qaeda was decimated
i respectfully suggest you ask yourself
this question
if we'd been attacked on september 11
from yemen
instead of afghanistan
would we have ever gone to war in
afghanistan
even though the taliban controlled
afghanistan in the year 2001
i believe the honest answer is no
that's because we had no vital interest
in afghanistan other than to prevent an
attack
on america's homeland and their friends
and that's true today
we succeeded in what we set out to do in
afghanistan over a decade
ago then we stayed for another decade
it was time to end this war
this is a new world
the terror threat has metastasized
across the world well beyond afghanistan
we face threats from al-shabaab in
somalia
al-qaeda affiliates in syria and the
arabian peninsula
and isis attempting to create a kayla
fight in syria and iraq and establishing
affiliates across africa and asia
the fundamental obligation of a
president in my opinion
is to defend and protect america
not against threats of 2001
but against the threats of 2021 and
tomorrow
that is the guiding principle behind my
decisions about afghanistan
i simply do not believe
that the safety and security of america
is enhanced by continuing to deploy
thousands of american troops
and spending billions of dollars a year
in afghanistan
but i also know
that the threat from terrorism continues
in its pernicious and evil nature
but it's changed
expanded to other countries
our strategy has to change too
we will maintain the fight against
terrorism afghanistan and other
countries
we just don't need to fight
a ground war to do it
we have what's called over the horizon
capabilities
which means we can strike terrorists and
targets without american boots on the
ground or very few if needed
we've shown that capacity just the last
week
we struck isis k remotely
days after they murdered 13 of our
service members
and dozens of innocent afghans
and to isis k
we are not done with you yet
as commander-in-chief
i firmly believe the best path to guard
our safety and our security lies in a
tough
unforgiving targeted precise strategy
that goes after terror where it is the
day
not where it was two decades ago
that's what's in our national interest
and here's a critical thing to
understand
the world is changing
we're engaged in a serious competition
with china
we're dealing with the challenges on
multiple fronts with russia we're
confronted with cyber attacks
and nuclear proliferation
we have to shore up america's
competitive to meet these new challenges
in the competition for the 21st century
and we can do both
fight terrorism
and take on new threats that are here
now and will continue to be here in the
future
fishing in the united states to be
bogged down another decade in
afghanistan
as we turn the page
on the foreign policy
that has guided our nation our nation
the last two decades
we've got to learn from our
mistakes to me there are two that are
paramount
first
we must set
missions with clear
achievable goals
not ones we'll never reach
and second we must stay clearly focused
on the fundamental national security
interest of the united states of america
this decision about afghanistan
is not just about
afghanistan it's about ending an era
of major military operations
to remake other countries
we saw a mission
of counterterrorism in afghanistan
getting the terrorists and stopping
attacks
morph into a counter-insurgency
nation-building
trying to create a democratic cohesive
in united afghanistan something that has
never
been done over many centuries of
afghan's history
moving on from that mindset
and those kind of large-scale troop
deployments will make us stronger and
more effective
and safer at home
and for anyone who gets the wrong idea
let me say clearly
to those who wish america harm
to those who engage in terrorism against
us or our allies know this
the united states will never rest
we will not forgive will not forget
we'll hunt you down to the ends of the
earth and we will you will pay the
ultimate price
and let me be clear
we'll continue to support the afghan
people through diplomacy
international influence and humanitarian
aid we'll continue to push
for regional diplomacy engagement to
prevent violence and instability we'll
continue to speak out for the basic
rights of the afghan people especially
women and girls as we speak out for
women and girls all around the globe
and i've been clear
that human rights will be the center of
our foreign policy
but the way to do that is not through
endless military deployments
but through diplomacy economic tools and
rallying the rest of the world for
support
my fellow americans
the war in afghanistan is now over
i'm the fourth president
who has faced the issue of whether and
when to end this war
when i was running for president
i made a commitment to the american
people that i would end this war
today i've honored that commitment
it was time to be honest with the
american people again
we no longer had a clear purpose in an
open-ended mission in afghanistan
after 20 years of war in afghanistan i
refuse to send another generation of
america's sons and daughters
to fight a war
that should have ended long ago
after more than two trillion dollars
spent in afghanistan
the cost that researchers of brown
university estimated
would be over
300 million dollars a day for 20 years
in afghanistan for two decades
yes the american people should hear this
300 million dollars a day for two
decades
you take the number of one trillion as
many say that's still 150 million
dollars a day for two decades
and what have we lost as a consequence
in terms of opportunities i refuse to
continue to war that was no longer in
the service of the vital national
interest of our people
and most of all
after 800 000 americans
serving afghanistan i've traveled that
whole country
brave and honorable service
after 20
744 american servicemen and women
injured
and the loss of 2
461 american personnel including 13
lives
lost just this week
i refuse to open another decade of
warfare in afghanistan
we've been a nation too long at war
if you're 20 years old today
you've never known an america at peace
so when i hear that we could have should
have
continued the so-called low-grade effort
in afghanistan
at low risk to our service members at
low cost
i don't think enough people understand
how much we have asked of the one
percent of this country
who put that uniform on
willing to put their lives on the line
in defense of our nation
maybe it's because my deceased son beau
served in iraq for a full year before
that
well
maybe it's because of what i've seen
over the years
as senator vice president and president
traveling these countries
a lot of our veterans and their families
have gone through hell
deployment after deployment
months and years away from their
families
missed birthdays
anniversaries empty chairs of holidays
financial struggles divorces
loss of limbs traumatic brain injury
post-traumatic stress
we see it in the struggles
many have when they come home
we see it in the strain on their
families and caregivers
we see it in the strain of their
families when they're not there we see
it in the grief borne by their survivors
the cost of war
they will carry with them
their whole lives
most tragically
we see in the shocking and stunning
statistic
that should give pause to anyone who
thinks
war can ever be low grade
low risk or low cost
18 veterans on average
who die by suicide every single day in
america
not in a far-off place
but right here in america
there's nothing low grade or low risk or
low cost about any war
it's time to end the war in afghanistan
as we close 20 years of war and strife
and pain and sacrifice
it's time to look at the future
not the past
to future that's safer
to future that's more secure
to future that honors those who served
and all those who gave what president
lincoln called
their last full measure of devotion
i gave you my word with all of my heart
i believe
this is the right decision
a wise decision
and the best decision for america
thank you
thank you and may god bless you all
and may god protect our troops
you